francis tiapa went from sleeping in the  tennis center storage room where his dad  was a custodian to beating rafael nadal  and now playing in the semi-final of the  us open he grew up using handed down  racket handed down clothes handed down  shoes while spending a lot of time at  the tennis center his love for the game  quickly grew he got good fast at age 10  he was beating 12 year olds and older  misha kuznetov tiafoe's coach while  growing up was all in on tiafoe he took  giaco to tournament paid his fees and  did anything he could so tiafa could  succeed years later francis tiato was  the first american man to reach the semi  since 2006 and he's the first black  american man to reach the semifinals  since 1972.